what was the biggest surprise for you
either player that was or wasn't tagged
what's the one that made you say wow
there were a few mike and i was sort of
surprised that the lions didn't tag
kenny
all day now i personally would not have
tagged him
based on what he did last season based
on
where the lions are in the rebuilding
process so i think it's a good move that
they didn't do it but we had heard that
they might do it
and they really liked him and really
wanted to keep him and maybe they still
will maybe they'll sign him to a long
term deal
who knows but this is a guy who only
played five games last season had 20
catches he had the hip injury and the
hamstring
hamstring injury but he is only 27 years
old if he stays healthy he's a good
receiver the question is can he stay
healthy going forward
we'll see if he gets the open market
what he gets on the open market and
maybe he returns the lines anyway but
a rebuilding team i think they needed to
let him walk away
and they did and i think it's a good
move by the lions but it did surprise me
a little bit
here's the dirty little secret that
agents and even teams don't like us
talking about but in a case like this
it's unescapable or inescapable as the
case may be i've been hanging around
sims too much
henny kenny gallaudet may have been
holding in last year that hamstring
injury
yeah that may have just been frustration
and not getting the contract he thought
he deserved from the detroit lions that
happens
and and it's it's dangerous ground to
make that accusation and i'm not
i'm not making it at all but it may not
be that he suddenly became injury prone
it may be that
in the last year of his contract without
the financial security for 2021 and
beyond
he he wasn't going to take any chances
and maybe he had hamstring tightness
that in a normal year
with full financial security he would
have played through so that's something
that
that anyone that's going to sign him to
a long-term deal is going to want to get
to the bottom of because
that helps explain why he did what he
did now of course you potentially become
a team that he does that to in the
future but it's not uncommon
it doesn't get talked about much but it
happens
guys hold out and sometimes guys hold in
and they typically do it when they're in
the last year of a contract
and they're not happy with the offers
they're getting and they're not willing
to go out and take the financial risk
that comes along with playing and
potentially getting injured before they
get
their payday so i i i i wasn't surprised
he wasn't tagged
and i won't be surprised if he gets a
good payday somewhere
my bigger concern about receivers
whether it's godwin
robinson who were tagged gallaudet who
wasn't you know we talk all the time now
about all the great receivers coming in
through the draft i wouldn't pay big
money to a receiver right now
i wouldn't make that huge investment on
a receiver right now i'm stunned
that the buccaneers tagged chris godwin
i thought they could just let him walk
away
scotty miller tyler johnson antonio
brown
and draft somebody you don't need to pay
that huge money to chris goblin when
you're already paying
market value to mike evans that's the
one that surprised me the move that
surprised me the most even though we
knew it was on the radar screen
i said holy something when i saw that
that had happened
yeah and mike back to gallaudet they
offered him 16 million
per season a year ago and he turned that
down i don't know that he gets that much
on the open market i certainly wouldn't
pay him that
much on the open market especially with
the salary cap going down like it is
i'm with you go draft a receiver michael
gallup for instance was a third rounder
tons of examples out there of second
rounders third rounders fourth rounders
who have developed into really good
receivers in the nfl they just
come out ready to play and we've seen it
year after year after year here lately
i love the receivers in this draft i'm
going to draft the receiver before i'm
going to give one of these guys
a huge contract i just think that's
probably the way to go right now with
the receivers because they're such good
receivers everywhere you look
also not tagged packers running back
aaron jones now
we had an estimate of over 11 million
dollars and it just
didn't make sense same reason why it
doesn't make sense to make that huge
investment in receivers you can get
running backs anywhere you can get
running backs
everywhere aaron jones has shown us
flashes of greatness but not the kind of
sustained
success that would justify the
eight-figure
one-year deal that potentially becomes a
market value deal
later in the offseason if he signed
before the july 15
deadline for doing that long-term deal
with a franchise tag player so
he hits the market will someone overpay
for aaron jones will someone not even
overpay just pay market value
there's a mindset among the agent
community
that running backs only get big money
from the team
with which they developed into a star
player
that on the market you're not going to
get paid kind of like
what you've already done or for what
you've already done
there isn't a fan base that's already
built in that wants to keep the guy
so we'll see i i remember somebody
suggesting 15 million a
year for aaron jones no no no no
no one's going to pay him 15 million on
the open market so we'll see
maybe he stays with the packers you know
some of these guys who are going to
become free agents now may look around
and realize
i'm better off staying where i am for
one year and becoming a free agent next
year when the salary cap is higher
he's certainly the best running back on
the market mike completely understand
why they didn't tag him but they do have
a hole there at receiver behind
aj dillon they have a bunch of nobodies
there and they have jamal williams also
is
scheduled to become a free agent and
tyler irvin so they need to have a plan
i'm sure they do what they're going to
do at running back
he's very valuable with what he's done
over the last two seasons for the
packers we've seen it he's been
outstanding for the packers
maybe somebody does over pay for him i
don't know but maybe they look at it and
say he's a running back and we don't pay
running backs big money
so it'll be interesting to see what
happens with aaron jones to me he's
one of the most interesting free agents
in this
class of free agents to see how he comes
out mike whether it's a long-term deal
or a one-year deal
it it it remains stunning to me
that packers fans get so triggered
whenever i say
or tweet or write that they should have
used the first round pick last year on a
receiver or the fourth round pick that
they used to
move up in round one to get jordan love
they wouldn't be in this predicament now
where they're so thin at receiver and
they have to worry about paying running
backs they've got
not that it's a ton of money invested
but it would have been a roster spot
a first round pick the slotted contract
that goes with it
on somebody who would have helped them
last year that's undeniable
no matter what jordan love becomes he
can become a hall of famer
he did nothing to help them win games
and get farther than the nfc
championship round
in 2020 when their window was open
windows open 2019
they didn't get to the super bowl 2020
they didn't get to the super bowl
with that receiver or whoever they would
have gotten who would have actually
played last year
could have been enough to make a
difference to get the packers
over the hump now they're going to have
to decide how much they can afford on
aaron jones
how upset will aaron rodgers be about
aaron jones possibly leaving these are
all issues that
the packers are going to have to work
out others who weren't tagged hassan
reddick who had that huge day against
the giants
five sacks if i'm a team in the nfc east
i'm very interested
in adding hassan reddick if i'm the
giants maybe i sign him so he doesn't
sign
with one of the other teams in the nfc
east hunter henry the chargers tight end
he'll be available to any team he was
tagged last year not this year john ooh
smith
the texans tight end chris carson the
seahawks running back that's no surprise
he's got chronic injury issues
shaquille griffin chargers corner he
wasn't tagged but duprey i
we we had a exchange on the pft text
chain
when when i think it was shefty who
breathlessly reported that bud dupree
isn't going to be tagged no crap he
wasn't going to be tagged
of course he's recovering from a torn
acl and then it had to give him a 20
raise over his tag number for last year
of course oh he's informed he isn't
going to be tagged well then he's the
last person to know he wasn't going to
be tagged shireen
well yeah kevin colbert already said he
we aren't tagging anybody this year i
mean it was obvious he wasn't going to
be tagged
but dupri already knew he wasn't going
to be tagged he should have taken the
long-term deal
a year ago he and dak share the same
agent they both bet on themselves
even though dak had his injury it worked
out for him it did not work out so well
for bud dupree mike
and i think he's probably going to have
to settle for a one-year deal with
somebody i don't see
anybody offering him really big money
not knowing how he's going to come off
that acl
injury when he's going to come back all
those sorts of things too many questions
with him i think he's going to have to
do a one-year deal bet on himself again
and maybe even have to prove himself in
2022
to get the big deal that he's still
looking for
the injury risk that you carry under the
franchise tag is more significant
for someone other than a quarterback
because quarterbacks have extra
protections and even then
dak prescott has that badly broken ankle
and he still gets the long-term deal
the next year but for dupree it was a
calculated risk and it's a shame and
again to echo
the criticism from last week of dan
campbell the lions coach who was acting
like it's a great thing to be franchise
tag no it's not
because while it pays very well for one
year it delays by at least a year the
opportunity to go to the market and get
maximum value generational wealth the
kind of fair
market return that players rarely get
and that owners rarely give and they
only give it to the best players who are
in position to get to the market this is
all part of the device and
it's fun it's exciting i'm not
complaining about having things to cover
but it would be better for the players
if there wasn't
a franchise tag deadline because there
wasn't a franchise tag
and they all became free agents when
their contracts expired but you know
what shireen
people in the media will huff and puff
and players in the union will huff and
puff from time to time about it
the reality is the franchise tag will
never
go away because the concession
that the players would have to make to
get the owners to give it up even if it
was on the table
first they got to put it on the table
even if it was on the table to give up
the concession would be so much it
wouldn't be worth it
yeah exactly right mike it's never going
to go away from a media standpoint we
love it today was fun it was a great day
and
i don't know why they have a week of
doing this we don't need a week we need
one day to say hey
deadline is march 9th at 4 pm tag them
when you want to tag them and we all
know they're going to mostly happen
today i guess we got justice simmons
early right that was
that was the only one confirmed by the
team before today but it was a fun day
so i like it from a media standpoint for
a player standpoint
probably not so much and it will be
interesting mike among these players we
know they'll probably be some who are
going to hold out at least through the
off-season program
to make their point that they're not
happy with the tag
july 15 is the next deadline that's
relevant
for the franchise tag players that is
when the window closes on
a long term deal you know once upon a
time
the rule was that the windows stayed
open until april 15
and then closed until july 15 and then
as of july 15 that's when they could
negotiate toward a long-term deal never
made sense and they got rid of that
about 15 years ago
now you have until july 15 and that's it
until the end of the regular season
so we'll see how many of these guys get
long-term deals
a lot of it's going to be driven by
where the salary cap is we still don't
know
with the salary cap is going to be we do
know where dak prescott is going to be
he's going to be in dallas at least for
the next four years
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports